salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler du
venezuela ce pays c'est un peu
l'eldorado pour une parti d'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite française
pourquoi et bien parce que depuis
l'accession au pouvoir en 1999 de chavez
le pays sous une politique socialiste et
nationaliste avec une forte composante
anti américaine de quoi plaire à ces
deux extrêmes mais depuis quelques temps
on parle d'hyperinflation de crise
politique
les jobistes au pouvoir eux parlent de
menace fasciste voire même de risque
d'invasion du pays aussi on va essayer
de comprendre quelle est la situation
réelle du pays et pour cela je vous
propose deux vidéos
cette première vidéo dans laquelle on va
voir quelle est la situation de pays
sous chavez entre 99 et 2013 et dans une
seconde
on verra quelle est la situation du pays
depuis sa mort allez c'est parti
j'en tire les conclusions
dans cette première vidéo de voir quelle
est la situation du venezuela entre 99
et 2013 sous l'ère chavez
mais tout d'abord pour bien comprendre
la situation du pays à ce moment là on
peut pas faire l'économie d'un peu
l'histoire du venezuela au xxème siècle
pour 20e siècle le venezuela
contrairement à pas mal de pays voisins
a été relativement épargné par la
dictature
puisque la démocratie existe sans
discontinuer depuis début des années 60
c'est qu'ils ont fait une exception sur
le continent sud américain
cette particularité et dur fait que lors
de l'instauration de la démocratie
1958 et trois grands partis d'alors à
coppet un parti chrétien social
l'action démocratique un parti
social-démocrate et lueur d un parti
centriste ont signé un pacte appelé
pacte de punto fijo engageant chacun
d'entre eux à respecter le choix des
urnes
cet accord a permis de stabiliser la
démocratie mais n'a pas que des
avantages
en pratique il rapproche les parties il
est perdant aux élections great souvent
de poste ministériel créant une
impression de caste qui se partageraient
le pouvoir
depuis cette époque entre 1958 et 1998
celle-là copé et l'action démocratique
ont le pouvoir
le pacte de punto fijo également eu
comme conséquence de marginaliser le
parti communiste vénézuélien dans
certaines franges ont alors basculé dans
une guérilla
très vite neutralisé globalement c'est
donc la gauche modérée et le centre qui
ont dirigé le pays
à côté de sa stabilité politique le
venezuela a une autre particularité il
possède la première réserve mondiale de
pétrole et la prospérité et la paix
sociale dans le pays ont toujours été
appuyée sur la rente pétrolière
l'industrie pétrolière a d'ailleurs été
en partie nationalisée par le président
social-démocrate perez dès 1976 créant
au passage pour chapeauter le secteur la
paix des bsa pétrole du venezuela
société anonyme
au niveau économique le pays dépend
fortement du pétrole qui représente
aujourd'hui 96 % de ses revenus due aux
exportations est grosso modo 50% des
rentrées fiscales
le pays s'est longtemps appuyé sur cette
rente
ce qui fait qu'il a une production peu
diversifiés et que la plupart des biens
de consommation sont importés notamment
des états unis
par ailleurs le venezuela souffrent des
mêmes maux que pas mal d'autres pays
d'amérique latine
au niveau agricole le pays est dominé
par deux grands propriétaires terriens
qui laisse les petits paysans sur le
carreau et socialement il souffre d'une
fracture ethnique des populations
pauvres qui représentent la majorité de
la population étant surtout constitué
d'un arrêt de matisse
alors que les catégories supérieures
sont plutôt blanche malgré ses travers
le pays fonctionne correctement jusqu'au
début des années 80 à ce moment là le
pays connaît une première crise
économique due à la baisse du prix du
pétrole la paix sociale et la prospérité
du pays reposant entièrement sur le
cours du baril une baisse du prix de ce
lycée entraîne fatalement une crise
économique
en 1989 pour sortir de la crise le
gouvernement social-démocrate leur
dirigé par perez le même qui avait
nationalisé le secteur pétrolier 13e
rang avant prend des mesures libérales
il est soutenu par le fonds monétaire
international
jamais avare en bons conseils oui déjà à
l'époque les faits me ne jurait que par
la libéralisation
résultat il ya des manifestations à
caracas elle tourne à l'émeute
la répression fait des centaines de
morts et l'épisode sera connu sous le
nom de caracazo quelques années plus
tard en 1992 profitant de l'état de
tension sociale dans lesquels et pays
depuis la cure d'austérité libéral un
groupe d'officiers de gauche dont chavez
tente un coup d'état
c'est à cette occasion que le grand
public découvre cet officier encore
anonyme et il est temps maintenant se
pose la question qui est celle
hugo chavez est né dans une famille
modeste ses parents et instituteurs ils
rencontrent les idées révolutionnaires
dès l'adolescence puis à le perdre un
ami membre du parti communiste qui lui
donnera ses premières bases politiques
en lui faisant lire entre autres marques
c'est rosso une fois adulte dans les
années 70 il intègre l'armée et devient
officier au début des années 80 il
incorpore un cercle d'officiers proches
du parti communiste dont le but est de
faire un putsch
c'est à cette époque que chavez a
réellement commencé à se former
politiquement il a tenté de créer un
socialisme purement latino américains en
utilisant des figures des histoires de
venezuela
tout d'abord simone rodriguez a aussi
appelé robinson qui était un philosophe
et un précurseur de l'éducation
populaire
ensuite bolivar artisans de
l'indépendance du continent est
également disciple de rodriguez et enfin
ezequel amora qui a mené une révolution
agraire pour profit des petits paysans
cette idéologie composite il appelé
l'arbre trois racines
il s'agit en fait de construire une
forme de nationalisme social dans lequel
le volet social est garantie par des
figures historiques qui n'ont pas lutter
que pour l'indépendance mais aussi pour
la justice sociale pour ne pas créer un
imaginaire exclusivement guerrier comme
c'est souvent le cas avec les
nationalismes
toujours est il que le groupe de
putschistes profite en 1992 de la
tension sociale dans laquelle pays
depuis la réforme de libérale pour
tenter son coup d'état mais il ne s'agit
nullement d'une improvisation puisqu'il
attend depuis plus de dix ans le moment
propice pour déclencher l'opération le
coup d'état est un échec militaire au
moins de 24 heures l'affairé réglée mais
c'est une victoire politique
lors de sa reddition charest se passe à
la télé explique sa démarche et déclare
que ce n'est que partie remise pour
panier ross mais voilà la capitale
sept apparitions médiatiques ont fait un
héros pour les classes populaires et
paradoxalement dans sa carrière
politique
après ce coup d'état avorté j'avais
libéré au bout de deux ans et commence
sa carrière politique il crée son propre
parti le m5 est un mouvement prend la
5ème république se présente à l'élection
présidentielle de décembre 98 mène
campagne sur les thèmes de la création
d'une nouvelle république plus sociale
et de la lutte contre la corruption est
finalement remporté l'élection
j'avais cependant que les rênes du pays
en 1999 avant de continuer une petite
précision vocabulaire et chavistes parle
de révolution bolivarienne république
bolivarienne voire même d'armé
bolivarienne ils ont même rebaptisé la
mane le bolivar fuerte il met bel hiver
en fête à toutes les sauces c'est
clairement une instrumentalisation
puisque bonne humeur était un militaire
du 19e siècle
il n'était pas socialiste est un pur et
ne cautionnerait probablement pas en
fait la politique du gouvernement actuel
aussi pour ne pas cautionner cette
captation d'héritage de les employer le
terme bolivarien mais systématiquement
le terme terroristes
comme on l'a vu hier et se fait élire
sur des propositions simples une
nouvelle constitution plus sociale et la
lutte contre la corruption
il n'affiche aucune idéologie précise
bien qu'il instrumentalise déjà bolivar
au début de son premier mandat il semble
chercher une voie médiane entre le
socialisme et le capitalisme sauvage
mais déjà à ce moment là sa politique ne
plaît pas à tout le monde et en 2002 il
est victime d'une tentative de coup
d'état de la part de la droite et du
patronat tentative un petit peu trop
vite applaudi par les usa mais je
reviendrai sur cet épisode dans la
deuxième vidéo
à côté de cela une cite également le
christ ou marx mais à partir de 2006 il
se radicalise et commence à parler de
socialisme du xxième siècle et anti
capitalisme c qui est une forme de
retour à son idéologie de jeunesse de
l'arbre aux trois racines sur le social
est à pour les westerns êtes un gamer
c'est à côté de cela au niveau
international il également des alliances
on avait certains pays considérés comme
être du mal par les usa d'époque
notamment l'iran et la libye
si on se fie uniquement au discours de
chavez on a l'impression qu'ils marchent
lord a par contre si on regarde ses
actes et ses pratiques politiques là on
peut voir des constantes depuis 1999 et
c'est à ces actes et c'est parti qu'il
faut s'intéresser pour vraiment
comprendre et xavi sont d'abord il y un
style chavez qui apparaît très vite
c'est un style populiste dans lequel le
président est en contact direct avec le
peuple
par exemple il crée une émission
hebdomadaire alo presidente et dans
laquelle il parle à la population
parfois pendant des heures à partir de
l'émission se double d'une autre alo
presidente et théorico qui explique les
fondements idéologiques du régime
sioniste clairement c'est une émission
de propagande dans le même genre de
culte de la personnalité et créer une
fête nationale pour commémorer son
putsch raté de février 92
ensuite j'avais entretient un rapport
difficile avec le pluralisme
démocratique
par exemple au niveau syndical qu'il va
chercher à contrer la ctv le syndicat
historique vénézuélien parce que celui
ci a participé à la tentative de coup
d'état en 2002 en créant son propre
syndicat l'unité mais cette unité va se
révéler trop peu de shalit à son goût et
il va créer en 2008 un nouveau syndicat
la c b st la création de ces syndicats
ne pressions pas simplement à une lutte
contre les organisations et du pouvoir
mais bien en fait à une création d'un
syndicalisme aux ordres au parti au
pouvoir de correspond
un syndicat qui va défendre sa politique
dans les entreprises c'est ce qu'elle
chérit s'appelle le parallélisme
syndicale tout aussi problématique en
2004 comme le prévoit la constitution
une pétition regroupant deux millions de
signatures provoque un référendum sur la
destitution de chavez le référendum
échoue et le pouvoir se venge en
divulguant les noms des deux millions de
signataires certains perdront leur
emploi
de quoi décourager toute action légale
contre le pouvoir un dernier point
important et constant dans le politique
de chavez c'est son instrumentalisation
du militaire son projet politique est
fortement marqué par les figures
guerrière commémorera ou bolivar et il
croit en la liant entre le peuple et le
militaire pour instaurer la justice
sociale il va donc s'efforcer tout au
long de son mandat de renforcer les
liens entre les deux pour cela les cha
listes vont mettre en place ce qu'ils
appellent une alliance civique aux
militaires en pratique ils vont créer la
milice bolivarienne une sorte de réserve
militaire
jusque là rien d'anormal sauf que cette
milice suit des cours de formation
théorique sur l'idéologie du régime
aujourd'hui le gouvernement voudrait
atteindre le chiffre de 2 millions de
réservistes pour un pays comptant 30
millions d'habitants
ce mélange vie politique et le militaire
est extrêmement important pour le régime
comme on peut le voir ici sur le site du
psg le parti de chavez ou c'est
clairement cette imagerie qui est mise
en avant
de son côté l'armée a aussi droit à des
cours de formation théorique et il a
écrit jusque dans la loi que les soldats
doivent être formés à l'idéologie
cabistes on voit ici une loi de 2009 qui
stipule clairement quels sont les
idéologues qui doivent être enseignés
aux soldats
rodriguez bolivar et zamora les piliers
de l'arbre trois racines
politisation l'armée et militarisation
de la société
très clairement le rapport aux
militaires et l'un des points les plus
problématiques du tchad ixo ce n'est
jamais bon signe d'une démocratie ce
midi charisme même si c'est pour
garantir la justice sociale la politique
sociale chimiste est plus simple à
résumer car elle a été globalement
constante de 1999 à aujourd'hui
dès son arrivée au pouvoir chavez
développe une politique sociale qu'il va
très vite financées avec l'argent du
pétrole
pour cela le gouvernement renforce son
pouvoir sur le pdv ça il va utiliser
l'argent de l'entreprise pour financer
différents programmes sociaux sertic
hull autour de sujets thématiques qu'il
appelle mission sociale ses missions
sociales sont nombreuses et touchent à
tous les aspects de la vie des
populations pauvres
il y a des missions éducatives qui
favorise l'accès à l'école que ce soit
au primaire au secondaire voire au
supérieur comme l'émission rivas
robinson
il y a des missions visant à favoriser
le retour à l'emploi comme la mission de
che guevara qui subventionne des
coopératives ou les petits paysans
il y a des missions médicales qui
propose des consultations gratuites
quand l'émission milan gros ou barrio
adentro il ya également des missions de
rénovation urbaine de la promotion du
sport de la culture de la citoyenneté
il ya même une mission qui a créé une
chaîne de magasins alimentaires la
mission berkane au total aujourd'hui il
existe une grosse trentaine de missions
qui forme un véritable parcours de vie
encadrant les populations pauvres
quasiment du berceau à la tombe
mais le mode de fonctionnement et de
financement des missions sociales pose
problème
l'argent provient de la paix des bsa une
entreprise et les fonds alloués ne sont
ni voter ni contrôlées par le parlement
et ce alors même que les missions
sociales ont une place extrêmement
importante dans la politique de l'état
pour vous donner une idée du coût de ces
missions est de l'implication de la
pdvsa
voici quelques chiffres les dépenses
sociales de l'état représentaient 8 2%
du pib en 1998 et sont passés à 20,9 en
2006 en fait les dépenses de l'état sont
passées de 8 2% à 13 6% du pib
les 7,3 pour cent restants sont en fait
clochers dans les fonds de la pdvsa qui
prend donc à sa charge un tiers des
dépenses sociales du pays de plus les
fonds dépendent du revenu pétrolier et
si les bénéfices de la paix des bsa
diminue en raison de la baisse du prix
du pétrole
toutes les missions sociales sont
compromises
ce qui fait que les budgets ne sont pas
sanctuariser toujours est il que
l'investissement massif dans le social
porte ses fruits car le taux de pauvreté
passe de 49 4% des populations en 1999 à
27,8 pour cent en 2010 sur la même
période
en moyenne les pays d'amérique latine
sont passés d'un taux de pauvreté de 43
18 % un taux de 31 4%
le venezuela par nombre de plus loin que
beaucoup de ses voisins et fait mieux
alors quel bilan provisoire tiré des
années de gps comme on l'a vu au niveau
social et politique juriste repose
entièrement sur les fameuses missions
sociales qui au delà de leur mode de
financement problématique aux questions
dans une démocratie en arrosant les
classes populaires d'argent j'avais ce
les attaches électoralement sans pour
autant forcément réglé les problèmes de
fond par exemple créé les magasins
mercal ne règle pas le problème de
dépendance du pays aux importations
subventionnées des coopératives ne règle
pas le problème de débouchés de celle ci
au niveau politique et théorie et
pratique chez liszt pose également
question comme on l'a vu dès son arrivée
au pouvoir il instaurer une cinquième
république avec une idéologie officielle
le bolivarisme qu'il a ensuite diffusées
dans la société notamment via les
ministres bolivarienne et des émissions
de propagande en fait son élection n'a
pas simplement été une alternance ou une
alternative vis-à-vis d'anciens partis
jugés dépassés mérité une forme de
changement de régime et ce changement de
régime quand on y ajoute le clientélisme
populaire pose question pour une
démocratie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le venezuela est
toujours une démocratie au sens où elle
était avant l'arrivée de tirer au
pouvoir mais dans les faits chavez a
toujours respecté le fonctionnement
démocratique et jusqu'en 2012
il a gagné toutes les élections de façon
nette et avec une abstention en baisse
ce qui légitime d'autant plus les
résultats même si les programmes sociaux
clientéliste ne sont probablement pas
pour rien dans cette victoire continue
en fait son élection a rappelé aux
classes moyennes que les pauvres aussi
pouvaient voter et qu'ils étaient
majoritaires dans le pays étant que
chavez s'assurer leur soutien dans un
pays où l'argent du pétrole coule à
flots il y avait peu de chances qu'une
alternance se produisent malgré les
dérives du régime sans un bouleversement
extérieur pour provoquer une crise et
donc jusqu'en 2013 le régime est stable
et soutenue par la population élection
après élection est ce que l'on puisse
penser de ces pratiques et de leurs
conséquences sur la démocratie
vénézuélienne
et bien voilà cette vidéo en forme de
bilan du che visse me 2,99 à 2013 touche
à sa fin j'espère qu'elle vous aura
permis de comprendre un peu la situation
du pays dans une prochaine vidéo où on
verra quelle est la situation au
venezuela depuis 2013
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine